it's call me on commie action Bernie
Sanders campaign manager is denying liz
warrants claimed that Bernie said a
woman couldn't win the presidency then
he blames Trump this is the story that
was obviously put out by unnamed folks
you know he was invited Bernie was
invited to senator Warren's house she
told him she was running for president
for anybody to say that a woman can't
win it doesn't make sense Hillary
Clinton won three million more votes
than Donald Trump in the last election
so there's some wires crossed here but
clearly Bernie Sanders did not say that
a woman could not win there was a
discussion about Trump misogyny a sexism
in politics and and and the difficulty
of running in the era of Trump for women
to special challenges that women face in
the era of Trump but you know those
conversations can sometimes get
misconstrued misconstrued ah yes the
three steps of identity politics the
hokey-pokey of the left first screw
qualifications focus on skin color or
gender for that protective bubble of
grievance second always use the worst
interpretation of a person's intent if
someone says they don't eat brown M&Ms
they must be racist
so misconstrue and deny good faith
without both you have no bigotry third
find common ground by blaming Trump
because you know he's evil despite doing
more for minorities than the clowns
running against him if not find any
white guy like Sanders it's hard not to
love this to watch the crocodile that is
identity politics eat the party that fed
it for years relegating candidates two
warring collections of traits and
grievances each now buys for the most
depressed but since they already smeared
half the country the only people left to
destroy are themselves so it's not a
fight between left and right but lives
who now see there's no escape from their
mindless angry peers look at Cory Booker
Stanford grad Rhodes Scholar Yale Law
Pro school choice in the city where
Democrats demolished public education
but even in his exit he made it about
identity they didn't lose cory booker no
they lost a black guy at some point the
Dems must realize that america is about
unity not difference Trump got that and
the only way to beat him is to pour his
opponents to do the same thing which
means four more years of Trump all right
one eye let's do a little quiz all right
four more years of Trump yes and I leave
now don't move to New Zealand we love
you all right who is okay if they're
this is the he-said she-said
or they said let's say that they said
just so the activists won't get mad
who is more trustworthy Bernie Sanders
or Liz who lied about being Cherokee
tried to cover up with a DNA test which
claims she was fired over being pregnant
a lied about helping companies escape
liabilities Sanders is not a liar she
lied she is not good at she cannot be
the nominee because how could she play
the character role with Trump like go
after his character she is a scheming
lying liar see mr. Trump you know I you
know it's not nice to bring it up but
Bernie's had some trouble claims of how
women were treated inside his own
campaign he's got a hands her for so I
don't know but I do think that when you
look at these two I would say that you
could see both sides being absolutely
true that she he was saying to her
Trump's a bully a sexist and it's going
to be hard for a woman to beat him and
look at what happened with Hillary last
time or you could have her saying but
what I'm hearing you tell me Mr Sanders
is that a woman can't beat Donald Trump
but if that's the case and by the way
that's a huge conversation right now you
don't have I mean you know you
there's only there'll be two women on
the debate stage tonight right yeah
Lauren and Klobuchar Yeah right
and much more qualified Klobuchar yeah
then will is one without a question but
I think that when you stop and think
about it the conversation goes well who
can beat Donald Trump if you're a
Democrat dude you trust a gay man would
you trust Pete buta Jay would you trust
a black person Cory Booker Obama was
presidents twice
welcome parent but not these guys
apparently aren't in that same category
and this is not the same moment in
history qualified running against Donald
Trump and you're looking at winning back
white males in swing states and so okay
how do you appeal to them who appeals to
them and I think lots of Democrats some
might say out of fear rather than
hopefulness are concerned that anybody
but a white male is going to have a more
difficult
well currently I can't believe I'm
agreeing with everything Juan just said
I think she had to announce and then out
of respect for Sanders they have to have
a meeting and she has to say hey Bernie
I'm running because he won millions of
votes last time he's kind of the
socialist heir apparents the right thing
to do and he maybe was a little offended
he she's in his Lane a little bit maybe
this was his turn and they start talking
as one said X's and O's didn't have a
great success running Hillary against
Trump last time Trump may match up
better against a woman for a certain
reason we don't know what it is talking
you know shop talking politics and she
may be interpreted that as a sexist
comment I doubt it
Murphy she's a liar as you also agree
with one I have to agree yesterday this
helps Biden because the two people that
are dividing the left-wing vote are
fighting each other now but Bernie hex
to extricate himself from this smoothly
because if he does get the nomination
he's going to need these war and votes
but at the same time
Liz Warren I don't know how she gets on
the ticket but if she does get on the
ticket she can't tee off Bernie Bros
because Bernie bros I think like ten
percent of the last time voted for Trump
so she can't antagonize his voters too
much and call him a sexist because if
she ever gets that nomination she's
gonna need Bernie's people you know what
the other thing that bugs me about this
whole thing Dana is it was in a private
meeting and that makes her not just a
liar but I think she's a lying think I
also wonder what's a think I think it's
a wrap no you what a wrapper Lance well
actually I don't know if he really said
it that way and but I do think that I've
long believed that if you are prone to
take offense about something you will
hear people offending you everywhere you
look yes and I think that there are some
times that people like Elizabeth Warren
that that happens to also I think nobody
saw it but on Sunday Rahm Emanuel the
former chief of staff to President Obama
former mayor of Chicago like every three
months he writes an op-ed begging the
Democratic Party to abandon identity
politics yes but no one's listening to
do that anymore at all and I saw today
that another Obama administration
alum said that he thinks because of what
Warren did with this leak of this
private conversation that the Native
American ancestry is now fair game
because you know what she say these
things he wouldn't go after Hillary's
emails I don't think he's going after
war on there there's a lot of character
problems real is Warren and I think we
see she can't be trusted and she's a
liar I've got three problems with her
pulling this stunt because obviously her
camp did number one it was too it was
too inflammatory because the reality of
that situation is probably actually how
you described which is a reality X's and
O's conversation where maybe he said
something to the effect of look I'm not
sure if this what you know you're
spitballing you're discussing and she
turns around and a rats him out and and
is obvious with it so we see her as
desperate and be it's quite plausible
him denying it being like I didn't say a
woman couldn't win like that's what you
know me Tulsi even did you guys see came
out today and she said I had that same
candid conversation with Bernie and he
showed me the greatest respect and
encouragement that he's known for so I
think he and his camp is again that
plausible deniability he's not that kind
of guy that would say oh hell no one
woman couldn't win like of course he's
not going to UM and then I think the
third thing there was a person in Iowa
actually that was quoted that I think
summed up this she's just a random voter
but that the the issue with Bernie
supporters is that they get the sense
that it's Bernie or no one but with
Elizabeth Warren but there's a broader
coalition that they believe that bigger
coalition might have the possibility and
the propensity to actually galvanize
more people and then that will get them
eventually that win so that's the other
side of that coin I think the Bernie
Sanders campaign has a lot better
organization better people you saw Jeff
Weaver there on camera giving a response
you don't see any of the warm people out
yeah one last thought on this is that
there's so much hurt left over from the
Clinton campaign in 2016 and a lot of
it's still directed at Bernie yeah and
so not only do the Obama people not feel
comfortable Bernie
neither do the Clinton people and I
think you're starting to see that come
out now but Bernie got the short end of
the stick too though right with the with
the debate so he has a reason to be
upset
anyway I'm tired of this topic are you
staring at me America four delegates
what with the super-delegates they're
not that super super duper